Trascrizione: Valentina Franzoni
Revisore: Ariana Bleau Lugo
Il coraggio lo cerco
per dire sempre quello che penso.
Il coraggio lo affronto per resisterti
negli occhi fino in fondo.
Il coraggio lo imploro
per tutti quelli che non hanno più
la forza di cercarlo.
Il coraggio lo odio
quando serve in battaglia
e sa di polvere da sparo.
Il coraggio non lo voglio
e non lo trovo
per reagire ai pugni chiusi.
Il coraggio tuo lo adoro
quando è libero nei tuoi versi.
Il coraggio poi mi uccide
quando mostra i denti stretti.
Il coraggio lo ritrovo
in un angolo del perdono.
Il coraggio non mi serve
per difendermi da un altro uomo.
Il coraggio lo conosco
quando muove rivoluzioni.
Il coraggio te lo scrivo
quando nasce una canzone.
(Applausi)